so your shell in the 1990s one of the
world's biggest oil companies you've
been exploiting nigeria's oil reserves
for a few decades now without caring too
much about the environmental damages
you've been causing but now you're
facing a problem the people of the agony
land a region in southeast nigeria with
large oil reserves have had enough of
your business and you can't blame them
oil spills and decades of waste dumping
have polluted their water supplies
people are forced to drink
cancer-causing substances with every sip
of water plus farming and fishing have
become close to impossible many men can
no longer feed their families
so now that you've destroyed their lands
made them sick and killed their source
of income a few stubborn protesters want
you out of their country that's not good
because if you lose control of nigeria
you lose out on billions in oil so what
do you do you call your best friend the
nigerian governments
see during this time shell was so
powerful in nigeria that they had the
entire military at their beck and call
yes a private multinational corporation
had an entire country's military in
their pockets
which is kind of like if amazon had the
u.s military at their beck and call and
shell wasted no time putting the
nigerian military to use you tell the
military to strike the protesters with
force no matter the cost
the results
widespread bloodshed a full-blown
assault on protesters that could only be
described by onlookers as quotes like an
invading army that have vowed to take
the last drop of the enemy's blood
80 nigerians dead almost 600 homes burnt
down all in the name of protecting
shell's bottom line in nigeria
but shell's fight against his opposition
was far from over and they were gonna
keep fighting as dirty as possible
this is the story of how one oil giant
sucked a country drive for all its gods
while leaving a wake of death
devastation and misery in its path
this is the story of how shells stole
nigeria
[Music]
[Music]
it doesn't matter how much money you
make if the world around you has been
destroyed that's why i'm super excited
to partner with ren ren is the easiest
way to make a difference in the
environment in less than three years ren
has raised over 2 million in funding for
environmental projects and they've
offseted over 154 000 tons of co2
emissions with ren all you have to do is
calculate your carbon footprint by
answering a few questions about your
lifestyle and then boom you find out how
big your carbon footprint is and how to
reduce it then you just choose how much
you want to donate every month it's
impossible to reduce your carbon
footprint entirely but it is possible to
cancel it out by funding positive
environmental projects every month
you'll receive updates from all the
projects you support you'll get to see
exactly what your money is being spent
on with photos and info about things
like every tree planted and every acre
reforested ren also helps a bunch of
different causes like preventing
wildfires and mineral weathering but one
that really stuck out to me was the tech
enabled amazon rainforest protection
project in peru the project provides
indigenous amazonian people with modern
tech like satellite monitoring and
drones to protect their rainforest from
deforestation
think about rent as an investment for a
cleaner brighter future for yourself and
the first 100 people who sign up using
the link below will have an extra 10
trees planted in their name go to the
link below to start off setting your
carbon footprint today thanks to rent
for sponsoring this video
[Music]
in 1833 a businessman named marcus
samuel decided to expand his london
antique shop seashells were all the rage
back then so he started to import and
sell them from the far east when marcus
samuel died his 2 says marcus jr and
samuel took over during a trip to the
caucasus in 1890 the region between the
black sea and the caspian sea connecting
europe and asia the two brothers came to
realize the huge potential of the oil
markets so they wasted no time and
started to restructure their business
they renamed it to the shell transport
and trading company due to their
father's passion for seashells the
rothschilds were active in the business
it built a considerable position they
had a problem though they couldn't
sufficiently market their oil they
needed markets and they were interested
in markets in particular in the far east
where their potential was very great
they knew a person who traded in the far
east who he thought had the vision and
the guts and the drive to uh to work
something out and that was marcus samuel
having met the rothschilds marcus samuel
recognized that he had a fantastic
opportunity to create a new global oil
trading company
he also knew that it was going to be
very risky and dangerous because he was
going against the most powerful
international company john d rockefeller
standard oil and he knew that standard
oil would do everything it could to
frustrate and prevent
this new venture from getting off the
ground by 1907 the company merged with
the royal dutch petroleum company and
royal dutch shell was born they quickly
became known as shell the finances of
the company had become quite dilapidated
and finally one of samuel's key
employees told him
the only hope for survival of this
company he'd created and that he really
loved was to merge it with deaderding's
royal dutch
shell's main goal was to compete with
john d rockefeller's oil company
standard oil the rockefeller was pretty
well everywhere in fact i suppose the
nearest comparison i can think of would
perhaps be
ibm in the 1960s or 50s a huge share of
the world market
and therefore if a newcomer was about to
start in one particular market he was
able to squeeze him out by just slashing
the prices in that one market
challenging rockefeller's oil empire was
quite ambitious but thanks to the huge
demand for gas and oil shell had many
opportunities to rise to the top
what is your petrol super shellwood i
see a super shell with icy a gift will
go for what you fake family motorist in
the no stop for super shell and go
during the first world war shell was the
main fuel supplier for the british army
and the only supplier of aviation fuel
and there's rather nice little quotation
in the front of it
saying without tolual without petrol and
oil fuel supplied by the shell
organization
the allies could not have beaten the
germans
what the first world war established was
the strategic significance of oil that
oil access to oil possession of oil the
ability to use oil would be a critical
element in national power and that was
one of the lasting lessons for the first
world war shortly after the first world
war shell accomplished their goal it
passed standard oil and became the
world's largest oil company but shell
was far from done it was time to keep
expanding but the problem with being an
oil company is that you can't just
produce more products out than air like
you would if you manufacture cars for
example now you actually have to go out
and find more oil reserves the problem
with that is that most countries are
protective of their oil reserves because
they know just how valuable it is that's
why you need to find oil rich countries
that are also poor that way even if they
understood how valuable their oil was
they wouldn't have the skills or
infrastructure to extract it so they
have to turn to someone like you but on
top of being poor we also need one more
ingredient one more qualification for a
country to have for us to want to take
advantage of them corruption
that way even if the people of the
country don't want to work with us we
can just bribe our way in abuse the
people of the country and still bribe
our way out of trouble everything
becomes easier when the government is
corrupt that's why by the end of the
1950s shell set its eyes on nigeria and
it would turn into a true nightmare for
its people
[Music]
so
in nigeria you wasted no time getting to
work
you form a partnership with nigeria's
governments to make sure that no one
comes between you and your billion
dollar profits when well heads exploit
and pollutes the people's water supply
you just shrug your shoulders and say
it's not your fault
you don't care if people's main source
of drinking water has been poisoned you
don't care that farmers have to stay
away from their own farms out of fear of
igniting a fire
or the few brave farmers who dare to
return to their home have to literally
swim through a sea of crude oil
due to the polluted water nigeria's
people were facing severe health risks
families were drinking cancer-causing
substances with every sip of water it
also had a devastating effect on farming
and fishing
the source of income is killed off all
of this pain and suffering led to
protests against shell they want to
shell out
they wanted these foreigners to stop
taking their wealth and destroying their
home but you were having none of it
with nigeria's government in your
pockets you allegedly go to them and
whisper in their ears if you want us to
keep lining your pockets you better get
the military to take care of those pesky
protesters and in an instance these
protesters fates were sealed
shell a private multinational
corporation now had an entire standing
army at its beck and call and the result
was brutal
guns went off grenades were thrown as
the military launched a full-blown
assault against all those protesters in
the end 80 people were killed and almost
600 homes were burned to the ground
witnesses saw the police rushing in but
like an invading army that vowed to take
the last drop of the enemy's blood end
quotes
shell now had a winning formula whenever
there was a protest nigeria's military
were rushed in to save the dead
in april 1993 the military wounded 11
people who were protesting against a new
pipeline a few days later troops opened
fired on protesters at a village killing
one man
michelle soon ran into another problem
the nigerian military was poorly
equipped to defend your oil operation so
he even allegedly provided the nigerian
military with boats buses and
helicopters and of course they also get
a nice paycheck for their violent
services
after nigeria's task force shot at
thousands of protesters outside of
shell's compound you feel nothing but
gratitude so you pay the responsible
general and its men a nice fee and you
tell them that you're looking forward to
collaborating with them more in the
future the military men rape the women
torture you they loot our properties and
their opponent houses but shell's
greatest enemy was still out there
[Music]
was a nigerian writer and environmental
activist he was also the president of
the mosop the movement for the survival
of the igoni people in 1993 he led a
non-violent protest against the
pollution of the agony lands land and
waters we are going to demand our rights
peacefully
non-violently and we shall win
[Applause]
remember the igoni land is a region in
southeast nigeria with large oil
reserves but that protest didn't go as
planned because in the following weeks
shell continued to expand its operations
in the agony land devastating more
communities in the process all with the
blessing of nigeria's governments in the
eyes of shell this activist ken sororiwa
proved to be a nuisance he was the most
stubborn protester you've faced so far
an idealist who was stopped by nothing
to get shell out of nigeria sara riwa
and his mosok group started to sabotage
shell's infrastructure and even
intimidated the shell's workers and his
strategy worked shell had to pause his
operations in the igoni land for a good
amount of time and every single day the
operations were paused you were losing
out on tons of profits all because of
one man shell have found a worthy
opponent and it needed to teach this guy
a lesson and here's the thing when
you're faced with a worthy opponent and
you have the opportunity to strike you
cannot hold back you cannot show any
mercy
why because if you only crush your enemy
partially they'll eventually recover and
seek revenge that's why the only way to
win is to crush your enemy totally we're
talking absolute brutality to make sure
that they can never get back up
so you allegedly sit down with nigeria's
governments and map out a plan to take
down sara wiwa and his mosop group once
and for all only three weeks later you
see your opening four of the local
chiefs were brutally murdered by a mob
of angry youth this was the perfect
opportunity to pin those murders on your
enemy saruiwa wasn't in the area that
day but that doesn't matter you
allegedly make sure that he's arrested
for enticing those murders allegedly pay
off a few locals to give false
testimonies at the trial and boom sorrow
we wash shell's number one enemy
suffered in jail for over a year before
they found him and eight other mosop
leaders guilty
on november 10th 1995 saruiwa and the
rest of the agony 9 were hanged by the
military
the message to the locals was clear get
in the way of shell's prophets and this
would be your fates
[Music]
so the present one they call me oh your
husband said you have to pick up his
stuff
so i took it
and i was just screaming crying
is this true that you guys already
killed my husband is gone
ah and some of them were just telling me
the story
what happened before my husband died
you say i was like
[Music]
i never imagined
this
and i never imagined that even 20 years
later the thing would still be so
painful as if it happened yesterday for
almost three decades the widows of the
agony 9 have been fighting for justice
but since they couldn't win a lawsuit
against shell in nigeria because while
the government was the main accomplice
they had to look for justice in other
countries oh my god they have very tight
relationships
when you see government it's a shock the
prosecution alleged that barone kyogle
whispered into the ears of some of the
attackers and from that they inferred
that he'd actually directed the killings
in 2017 the widows launched a court case
against shell in the netherlands the
court in the hague heard testimony from
five witnesses and some even admitted
that they had been paid by shell to give
false testimony which led to the
execution of the agony ix but the judges
decided that the efforts was just not
enough to hold shell accountable in the
end all shell had to say was a very
generic statement written by their pr
department
in 2009 michelle paid a measly 15.5
million dollars to some of the activist
families including sarah wiwa's family
compared the show's profits of more than
half a trillion dollars since 1990 they
probably weren't too worried about this
fine amnesty a human rights group
studied thousands of shells internal
documents and found that shell quotes
encouraged the nigerian military to deal
with the community protests even when it
knew the horrors it would lead to
unlawful killings rape torture and the
burning of villages end quotes
the internal shell records that we've
been through
show that executives encouraged the
nigerian government and military to deal
with these agony protests
that executives understood very well the
risks of inviting the nigerian army to
guard its contractors who are laying
this pipeline
but despite this they still insisted
that the operations go ahead
they were really buying
the special forces
for future assignments and to make sure
that they would keep doing their favors
and they were really not sending a
signal that killing people is out of the
order to this day shell denies any
involvement in the executions
[Music]
public is a social investing app where
you can easily invest in stocks etfs and
crypto with any amount of money and
millions of people are already taking
advantage of it public is a serious game
changer because you can follow other
investors right in the app to learn what
they invest in this gives you an unheard
of advantage never before seen in
investing now you don't have to just
listen to what people say and take their
word for it but you get to see where
people actually put their money because
as they say actions speak much louder
than words i'm also on public you can
follow me at jtran and what's great is
that the public app is free and there
are no commissions on standard stock
trades public always puts its investors
first they'll never sell your trades to
market makers and instead your trades
are rather directly to the exchanges and
with public you can buy small slices of
a stock etf or crypto instead of the
full share there are thousands of stocks
and etfs to choose from and over 20
different cryptos like bitcoin cardano
and ethereum and if you go to public.com
jake train and create an account you'll
get a free stock worth anywhere from
three to a thousand dollars that's
public.com to get a free stock with the
link below thanks to public for
sponsoring this video
[Music]
hope you enjoyed the video and if you
are new here my name is jake and we run
one of the biggest channels on youtube
for documentaries on money power and
crime so if you enjoyed this one click
that subscribe button below and click
that join button below too if you want
longer documentaries that are even more
controversial to the point where i can't
post them publicly if you join and you
don't think it's worth it there's a
refund policy too we have a very
exciting one coming out that is
definitely going to get demonetized if i
posted it publicly and i'm really
excited for you guys to see it you can
follow me on instagram jaytrain.io
that's going to wrap it up stay
dangerous out there and i will see you
guys in the next one
[Music]
you